we uh love having this man on the
program from cbs and
turner and also uh calls brooklyn nets
games locally in the metropolitan area
my friend iron eagle how are you hi and
eagle how are you hey
what's up rich how are we doing how are
you doing how are you i'm doing well
this has been the best playing
tournament ever
well i mean last night was the greatest
game in play in tournament history don't
you think that was good
it was we got to witness it greatest
half
definitely the greatest half i agree i
agree i agree
so the whole thing is like even with the
playing game have you called a play-in
game for the ncaa tournament yet or you
have not
uh have i done the first four yes
no but does that count does that count
as a tournament game though doesn't it
count as an action it does
yes it does count starts as it counts as
a win
100 they made sure to to
categorize it as a ncaa tournament game
right so what is last night last night
was just
well thanks for coming on i appreciate
it nothing like
truly it's it's bizarre any of the
numbers that you saw
last night the night before yeah it
didn't happen
they don't go anywhere they don't go on
your permanent record
they don't go into
basketballreference.com
they don't go into the nba handbook the
nba doesn't even have a handbook
it's all online none of it counts
by the way i don't know if my guys who
aren't from the new york
metropolitan area realize when you your
reference to permanent record
is a grade school reference correct
iron right am i correct so you like
like me they would always they would
toss that in in front of you
if you were ever leaning towards doing
something bad
this is going to go on your permanent
record
we grew up basically in the same world
and i got the same
second grade third grade teachers in
ps54
at staten island new york if if you do
this it'll go on your permanent record
and i always wonder
where are those records being kept now
we know with the state farm play in
tournament record books
that's where they are my
unsatisfactory in language arts from
1976 is sitting next to jason tatum's
50-point game
from the other night that's what you're
saying you are so right
mrs barry my fifth grade teacher i don't
even
i don't even want to tell you what was
being written up at ps 101.
it wasn't pretty and i was scared that
that would come back to haunt me like on
my wedding day
no stop stop we have his permanent
record
this is not gonna happen uh i hate to
tell you what sean mcmanus may have on
you right now based on new ps4 101
i feel the same way it's so funny i and
eagle here uh
on the rich eisen show um and then you
know uh
the brooklyn nets let's let's dive into
that one right now because
no matter what we saw last night um
and we saw a great game last night and
no matter what may happen
in the coming days there's the sense of
from the nba fan writ large that if
kyrie and hardin and durant are healthy
this thing is all just rearranging deck
chairs what is the sense from the nets
coming into this playoff series now
against the celtics what do you have for
me on that
fine i think the nets are really
comfortable with
where they are from a health point of
view from a chemistry point of view
the one question that keeps popping up
and
rightfully so for for people that want
to find holes
in this theory that the nets can't win a
championship
would be the lack of playing time for
the three
together but that's it that's really the
only thing that that you could point
towards
and these are three elite talents
i don't think it's going to be an issue
with them developing
a strong dynamic on the court chemistry
working through some things potentially
in this first round
they're not viewing it as a problem i
think there's been
a little bit of a build up from some
within the nba that the nets have taken
on this role as a villain
which is fine i think that that's
actually a good thing it's a good thing
for
the story lines for the narratives to
create
and maybe there is some truth to it
because
there are some people that don't like
the way the nets were built or
a super team how that's formed the
reality is anyone that's been around the
net organization knows this didn't
happen overnight
this took years there was a very
big culture shift and sean marx made
this a desirable place
to come to you don't snap your fingers
and just get great players
there's a lot that goes into it how this
all plays out
is a big part of the intrigue in the nba
playoffs
can this group come together and can
they do it
during the most important point of the
season they're going to be judged on
what they do in the postseason
they have the best winning percentage in
franchise history
it doesn't matter nobody will remember
that
they will be judged by their playoff
results
and they know it what has steve nash's
job been
like this year from your front row seat
that where kyrie kind of went on
walkabout a couple times and we all know
about durant
and his injuries as he was gone and then
harden gets hurt after
a late arrival um blake griffin
comes in i mean this this is a
first-year
head coach despite his greatness as a
player what what what has that been like
from your perspective yeah i think it's
it's probably gone under the radar
a little bit rich that he walked into
a situation that had very high
expectations almost a championship or
bust mentality and he kept this thing
afloat
they've won a bunch of games without
kevin durant
they've won a bunch of games without
james harden they've won a bunch of
games without
kyrie irving they problem solved they
figured some things out they willed
themselves to the finish line in a few
games where they didn't have
the talent that they expected to have on
the floor
and i think that's going to serve them
well once they hit the postseason that
it wasn't
all about the big three the others
carried their own weight
the season that jeff green put together
and joe harris and the contributions of
bruce brown
and landry shannon and blake griffin
later on when he joined the squad and
nicholas claxton it was a revelation
down the stretch
so all of that is something i would
put in the larger equation what i would
say about steve is
he just had the perfect temperament he's
handled
everything with incredible balance
he's never gotten too out of sorts he's
never gotten
too low he's never actually gotten too
high and celebrating
the wins and i think that's going to
serve him well now
going into uncharted territory for him
he's never been through this
never been a head coach certainly has
never faced a playoff series where
every decision could play a role in
whether you win a game or win a series
and you'll be held to a certain level of
scrutiny based on
those decisions that you make in game
he's well aware of it
he's really got the right
state of mind to do this job and he's
really turned out to be the perfect
person
to handle big personalities and his
ability to relate
to the superstar and then the 10th 11th
12th man
steve was not a sure fire superstar he
had to work
really hard to become the player that he
became
not saying that other guys don't work
really hard but he had to overcome
a lot of obstacles along the way people
that didn't think he could be at this
level and i think that's allowed him to
relate and connect
with everybody on the roster you know
and just in terms of you know uh
getting through a gauntlet um the
eastern conference is no
uh easy path obviously um
you know we're assuming they'll get past
the celtics quite
quite simply and then you know after
that
um it'll be either the defending
conference champs
um in the heat or the box and then
eventually the sixers
that said and then the western
conference is a crucible in its own self
but
yeah i mean lakers nets let's be honest
here that's
that's what would be the biggest
headlines and the biggest
storylines certainly from nash having
even a connection with the lakers and
durant and harder
mygosh and kyrie and lebron and anthony
daniel lebron created the super teams
with miami and then
kyrie and lebron i mean and then anthony
davis that would be
off the charts iron that would be yeah
amazing i think rich what's
what's really blown me away about this
this whole
season for the nets is how much they've
resonated
nationally and i knew that there would
be a lot more attention
and i was doing the games when they went
to back-to-back finals and jason kidd
was a messiah-like figure when he got to
new jersey he was the first one that
didn't care about the past
didn't care that they were always looked
at as an afterthought
or the younger brother in new york
new jersey basketball he just went about
his business and won a whole bunch of
games
but they never quite hit
on a national scale and the intrigue
the chatter the conversation
day in and day out it it's really amazed
me
uh how much the nets have have
registered on
on that level so everything you just
said is
is spot on i do think people want to see
it
there's a lot that has to be done before
we get to that point and i think
part of the real intrigue of the nba
playoffs this year
compared to previous years is that we
don't know who's going to emerge there
were years where we had a pretty good
inkling of
who would be the team and now based on
this
very strange regular season
you can't take all of your old tricks
of looking at the stats or looking at
the trends or just looking at home court
advantage
and say that it's going to translate in
this playoffs
we just don't know this is such a a
different vibe than previous years in
the nba playoffs even just home court
advantage which you fought for
so hard in previous years
i don't know if if the home records
really match up to what they used to
match up to once you hit
the postseason i just don't know this
year
based on the health and safety protocols
and how many fans are allowed in certain
arenas
travel is different everything is just
different so
with that said i think there's a lot of
anticipation once this thing really gets
going in earnest
ion eagle here on the rich eisen show on
even though things are different there
are some that stay the same and that's
how i'm gonna
end our conversation here by turning to
you and
trying to um you know ask you for your
advice
um and also delve into your
delve into your uh basketball knowledge
and also
a parenting parenting as well um you
yes i mean i you didn't expect this and
i'm throwing your curve here but
um last night my son my 12 year old son
xander
um sitting next to me he asks me this
question i even put it on twitter
so i'm wondering if you can help me what
i say to my son he said
dad why do they always call fouls just
because lebron wants it
and
i'm i'm wondering if you like what what
do i how do i end
as a father um who needs to tell him
about the way the world works and
you know understand uh how fraught with
uh
danger that might be giving him a
straight answer and also just basketball
knowledge as well
how do i answer that question of my of
my son xander
iron eagle yeah what a what a seminal
moment
that hits you doesn't it it hits you in
places that's another
yep it's like a switch you're the one
that's supposed to provide
all the answers yes in life you're the
one that he's supposed to turn to
forever
yes advice feedback
tips and you were
i assumed speechless yes at the moment
um and it was interesting because that
was the
moment uh where lebron took a charge but
uh steve kerr
challenged it come back from the
commercial break and it's a block and
that's when he asked me that question
like how come they call fouls just
because lebron wants it
and um i i didn't know really how to
answer such a question
that is at parts astute and also
disturbing you know i'm so that's why
i'm wondering you consider googling it
know that's a good go-to for you
i did not chris could you google google
that question see what the results come
up
google it yeah let me know let me know
yeah i know okay
because that that would probably be my
my first step my second step would would
probably be a much more in-depth
conversation about
how life isn't fair and
[Music]
you just need to know this at a young
age they're going to be
moments and experiences that pop up bad
there is no reasonable explanation
correct
that's okay right and then they would be
okay with that right and that there are
powerful people in the world who have
sway over individuals that uh that might
make a ruling that doesn't appear to be
appropriate at the time but um there's
such a thing as influence and there's
such a thing
as a block and a charge and and things
like that
like you know hold on let me write you
these are good for my son
i need to write this down what is it
what is that google research
on on how to talk to your kids okay this
is great well i will say there are
several articles let's see here's one
from 2019
lebron james is the king of all calls
2018. lebron wants all the calls
here's one from 2013. lebron james has
rarely called for fouls
i remember that one
manipulate refs there's all kinds of wow
oh yeah
see now it's a slippery slope
internet knows all see i love it
uh i and i knew you'd have the answer
again google it is the is
a great response pretty much oh my gosh
thanks for the call
i appreciate it when's your first video
when's the first game
is it sunday for you the first game is
saturday that's
a nationally televised game so we're
doing game two game three
and game four that's tuesday friday
sunday this is yes okay on yes very good
on yes okay yeah marv as we know is
retiring as well
um have you looked at well i just i just
don't want to say goodbye this is like a
jewish goodbye right now
uh did you look at the the nfl schedule
have you have you gotten yours yet when
does cbs tell
you when you and uh i did i took a look
i realized that that was a very slippery
slope to go down
i don't want to start booking flights to
imaginary assignments that i'm going to
get
and i started doing that i'm like oh
yeah and then
ultimately you get disappointed like so
it goes
i backed off it goes on your permanent
record on don't do it it goes on my
permanent record
that i booked a flight to buffalo yes
and i didn't get the buffalo assignment
by the way i think that's what you're i
think you're gonna get steelers at bills
i think that's you and charles davis
week one
that's what that looks like to me yes
sir i think that is a for sure
i think you're definitely getting that
and then you gotta boy
you this week two is patriots at jets
and also cowboys at chargers
i like it you're bringing me right back
in yeah yeah that's right
bringing me back i know and you've got
nets and celtics uh game two coming up
so
uh there's lots going on ayan thank you
for the call always appreciate it all
right guys
great talking to you good brother there
it is i'm eagle everybody here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here